gilles suite a choisi la salle des fêtes
d'orphin pour déclarer sa candidature
aux élections législatives lui entouré
de ses proches
il a tenu un discours fidèle à ses
convictions centristes et il me semblait
important d'être à côté d'un de mes amis
pour le lancement de sa campagne parce
que on partage des valeurs humaines des
valeurs politiques ensemble et je pense
qu'on a une envie comme une farouche de
faire de la politique autrement
gilles mas
c'est ce grand plaisir de me proposer
d'être sa suppléante de l'accompagner
dans cette belle aventure
et j'avoue que c'était le candidat que
j'aurais soutenu de toutes façons dans
une circonscription aux couleurs rural
les enjeux liés à ce territoire seront
au coeur de sa campagne
j'ai décidé le candidat pour participer
au débat démocratique
pour animer ce débat qui aujourd'hui
ne remplit pas ne répond pas à mes
attentes et ne remplit pas ne répond pas
aux attentes de beaucoup de concitoyens
concernant la ruralité le travail qu' on
va le mener c'est tout un travail
effectivement de maillage travail de
transport travail d'accès aussi d'un
réseau internet
la fibre on va travailler aussi sur
l'accès à la culture à la formation à
l'emploi
prochaine étape pour gilles schmitt
obtenir l'investiture de l'ue dei en cas
de refus du parti il maintiendra tout de
même sa candidature dans la 10e
circonscription et ira déchets le député
sortant et président du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson